hello I'm Ron Vale and today I have the
great pleasure to be speaking with Jim
Rothman and Randy Schekman who just
returned to the United States from
Stockholm where they received a 2013
Nobel Prize in Physiology or medicine
along with their colleague Tom soot of
this trio was awarded the prize for
their seminal work in uncovering the
molecular machinery that's involved in
membrane trafficking and protein or
neurotransmitter secretion this is a
journey of proteins through the cell
that starts with protein insertion into
the endoplasmic reticulum those proteins
are then recognized as cargo packaged
and then transported as small vesicles
to the next weigh station which is the
Golgi apparatus and from there they are
transported to new membrane destinations
such as the lysosome or the plasma
membrane and this trio of suit off
Rothman and Schekman found the molecular
machinery that's involved in each step
of this pathway through the cell so
thank you for joining us today and I'd
like to begin with the science and maybe
Randy I could ask you if you could
describe the work that Jim did that led
to his contributions for the Nobel Prize
happy to do that hmm I first met Jim
when he interviewed for a faculty
position at Berkeley as an assistant
professor I'd been there about a year
and he told me in broad terms about his
his plan which I certainly appreciated
being a biochemist and then he went and
did it at Stanford very quickly he
launched into developing a cell-free
reaction to reproduce traffic at least
initially he thought it was traffic from
the ER to the golgi subsequently it
turned out to be measuring traffic
vesicular traffic within the Golgi and
he used that to identify soluble
proteins that he called NSF for in ethyl
maleimide sensitive protein and then
snap which was the membrane
scepter for NSF and showed that these
were involved at some point in membrane
fusion and then in a really brilliant
experiment several years later he used
the the NSF and alpha snap complex bound
by non-hydrolyzable ATP analog to I to
fish out of membranes from a crude
detergent soluble fraction from bovine
brain the proteins that that turned out
to be the membrane anchors and the
likely catalyst for fusion which he
called snare proteins so it was a really
beautiful synthesis of biochemistry and
functional analysis and Jim maybe I
could ask you the same question could
you comment on the key discoveries and
contributions that Randy made that led
to his being awarded the Nobel Prize
this is a great pleasure to have a
chance to Randy and I have been joking
for a long time about giving each other
seminars so you've given us a great
chance to do that wrong Randy in the
starting in the late 1970s took on a
problem that was extremely adventurous
and people at that time model organisms
were not what they are today there were
very few examples where for example
yeast had been used to really forge
ahead and understand complex eukaryotic
pathways as Randy points out the yeast
cell cycle was one people doubted
actually that there was a secretory
pathway in yeast that reflected in any
way in any meaningful way the similarity
to the the Pilati pathway that we all
had understood at the time the golgi
apparatus if it was observed only was
only scantily observed and Randy and
Randy especially in a really innovative
approach was able to isolate a series of
mutations first based on kind of brute
screening and then after that based on
up a really important experimental
insight about if you have a cell that is
making protein but not excreting the
protein it's going to get denser and so
based on that Randy was able to isolate
a large number of mutations
systematically they essentially defined
the entire secretory pathway and the
major secretory organelles in yeast and
established the generality of the
pathway but more importantly they
provided the means to discover the
molecular machinery that is important in
various stages of vesicle budding and
fusion and it's turned out over the
years that the genes that Randy
initially discovered 23 of them play
pivotal roles at multiple stages of the
secretory pathway some at all stages of
fascicular trafficking his students and
and others have followed in his
footsteps and have essentially laid out
the entire map of this of the transport
pathways in the East cell so both of you
shared some interesting similarities in
terms of how your careers started you're
both trained as biochemist was in some
great laboratories and you then became
assistant professors both at a very
young age and then both of you picked
very risky problems to start your
laboratory so I'd like to get some
background of how you came up with this
project and how you decided to tackle it
so maybe I can start with you Randy
maybe you can just tell me how you ended
up choosing the problem membrane
secretion and also taking a genetic
approach near the end of my graduate
career in looking at the literature on
membranes largely influenced by Bill
Wigner was a postdoc in Arthur's lab at
the time and would also come from
Kennedy's lab that biological membranes
were likely to be a subject that had a
great one could learn a great deal about
biosynthesis you know one could possibly
treat a biological membrane as a macro
molecule and dissect its biogenesis
using the techniques of biochemistry and
genetics in a way that hadn't really
been applied yet so I went to John
singer's lab to learn about what he was
thinking about biological membranes and
I found myself on a project that didn't
really have a future in my mind it was
using a scarce material and I found that
working with mammalian cells at least at
that time in the mid-1970s was not as
satisfying as working with a
microorganism so I resolved when I when
I joined the faculty at Berkeley it
influences to some extent some large
extent I would say by the successively
Hartwell in his genetic section of the
cell division cycle that I would then
launch an independent career using some
kind of genetic analysis of membrane
biogenesis and Peter Novick
was one of my first graduate students
and it was my good fortune that he
joined my lab very thoughtful very
precise hard-working really brilliant
student and so we the two of us sort of
embarked on this effort to identify the
genes involved in secretion by genetic
approach we it was a kind of a trial and
error initially we had some crazy idea
about the need for a genetic selection
that didn't work
we found a mutant in spite of it being a
selection that didn't work we found the
first mutant anyway and we realized that
it was a complex pathway and that
probably just looking through random
assortment of temperature-sensitive
mutant just as Hartwell had done would
turn up more more genes and we did we
did find another one but then as Jim
mentioned earlier we we decided to use a
an enrichment procedure and isolate a
lot more mutations so it was a good
choice obviously it worked out well it's
not the traditional way that one starts
a career usually postdocs are a little
more conservative but I think it'll
always advise my postdocs to be more
bold and to do something new but of
course when you do something new there's
a good chance that you'll fail so what I
did was I started several different
projects this one worked within a year
and then I marshaled all of my efforts
to focus on that so as a follow up I was
wondering if you could explain the assay
that you use to get the sec mutant and
also your reaction to that amazing
electron micrograph in that figure six
of your
1979 paper that shows us yeast cell
filled with all of these vesicles that
could no longer reach the cell surface
so the idea was that in looking at thin
sections of yeast cells when one can see
some organelles that look like they
could be associated with secretion not
as dramatic as in a section of mammalian
cells but Novik and I guess that the
vesicles that once he is congregating
under the bud portion of a dividing cell
would would be the vehicle not only for
secretion but for assembly of the plasma
membrane and so we predicted that
anything that blocked there the
biogenesis of these vesicles would be
lethal and therefore one would have to
go after conditional
temperature-sensitive lethal mutations
so our that was the first and crucial
assumption that it was going to be an
essential gene and the second was that
the mutant would at a restrictive
temperature caused secretory proteins
which are otherwise very efficiently
secreted from cell from cells to be
accumulated inside of a cell and that
actually really trivial assay you just a
say intact cells which which measures
the enzyme has been trapped in the cell
wall cause cell wall is porous and then
you dissolve the cell wall with an
enzyme and you have Pharaoh plaster left
and you just ruptured the syrup last was
a church in the USA what's what's inside
the Serra flask and that that's measure
of accumulation in a wild-type cell that
that baseline is virtually zero in a in
a second it rises dramatically above the
background so the first mutant just
based on a biochemical enzyme assay was
really obviously blocked in multiple
secretory enzyme transport but the
dramatic result came just around the
time of George Pilate visited Berkeley
for a special lecture and I recall
Novick telling me that at a luncheon
Pilate had encouraged him with these
preliminary results to cut a thin
section look and see what these cells
look like and so we had an expert
technical assistant in the department
and that of course was one of the great
Eureka moments of my career when the
Novick excitedly excitedly called me
down to the e/m room and showed me this
SEC one cells sections that were just
like they had measles they were just
full of vesicles nothing nothing like
that it ever
at least never been published I don't
think it ever been seen before and from
that moment really literally from that
moment on I knew that we would have at
least several decades worth of
productive work well Jim let me ask you
a similar question you started off your
career at Stanford as a very young
assistant professor you had experience
with the vsv virus from your previous
work but you decided to tackle a very
difficult problem which was to try to
reconstitute parts of the protein
secretion pathway in a cell-free extract
and in fact many people thought that
wouldn't work and that it would be an
extremely risky project to take on so I
was wondering if you could give a little
bit about your thinking and the
background that led to that particular
project my exposure to this entire area
of biology began as a medical student in
my first year at Harvard Medical School
and George Pilates discoveries were
really fresh and they were presented in
my histology course and when I saw those
electron micrographs of vesicles and
endoplasmic reticulum and Golgi and so I
immediately started thinking given my
background in physical sciences how in
the world could such a vesicle form you
know what would make that happen how
would it know where to fuse and and I
must say somehow identified that problem
as one that I wanted to solve at some
point and I've got fixated on it and I
can't really tell you why but I just got
fixated I found it it's fascinating then
inside Junya and after leaving medical
school and finishing my PhD with Jean
Kennedy where I did learn some basic
biochemistry of membranes and lipids I
went to work with Harvey loutish for a
year or two and I did it with the
freedom of having my already my
assistant professor offering hands I was
able to do pretty much what I want and
focus on on really educating myself and
from Harvey and his colleagues I learned
how to work with complex cell free
systems we were using cell free extracts
that were synthesizing protein we
learned following the footsteps of
Gunter blobel how to how to study the
incorporation of those proteins in vitro
into the endoplasmic reticulum membrane
and that really equipped me very well
now when I went to Stanford in 1978 like
Randy I pursued several different
projects and that was a way of
distributing the risk but then again I
made a decision to focus intensively on
one project when we did have some
success with after some period of time
and that's the project you're referring
to the reconstitution of transport and a
cell-free extract and I think that
decision that Randy made in the decision
that I made is a very important decision
that young scientists can make which is
at some point you really have to focus
and you have to focus deeply on
something and in the long run if you
want to make a contribution that's
that's really worth making rather than
just simply incremental you have to
stick as Randy did and frankly as you
did run to to that decision it's not
always going to be easy it's certainly
not free of risk but it has great
rewards for science when you're
successful and so what we did was we
wanted to reconstitute transport from
the ER to the golgi so we took the cells
living we gave them a very short pulse
label with radioactive methionine and
you know tricks I've learned in Harvey
Lotus's lab then homogenized the the
cells to retain them in the end the G
protein in the endoplasmic reticulum and
then we incubated that extract to see if
the glycoprotein could be for the
process by adding certain sugar residues
especially in assets helical cosa meat
which we knew from the work of Phil
Robbins and Stewart Kornfeld occurred
and others occurred in the Golgi so if
we could see that processing in vitro it
suggested it would have suggested the
transport occur and indeed after I don't
know a month or two we observed that
that was the case we could see it but
that we had a huge background even
without any kind of an incubation of
longer than a few seconds even without
adding ATP or cytosol we still saw
processing and what we came to realize
was that we already had too much of the
g protein sitting in the golgi and it
was getting glycosylated directly
there so that gave me the idea of what
what is now known as a complementation
assay which is pretty much the standard
design for most so for in those days
most self RiRi constitutions of
transport and what the idea is you want
to mix two extracts one from a cell that
contains the cargo protein vsvg
but lacks the processing inside the
other extract from a cell that lacks the
processing enzyme but excuse me has the
processing enzyme but lacks the the
cargo protein and so when the two are
mixed if the cargo protein is getting
glycosylated it must have gone from a
donor membrane in the extract of the one
cell to the processing enzyme of the
Golgi of the other cell and so that
eliminated the background that I
referred to because they say the extract
with the vsvg protein was incapable of
processing by adding sugar so we when we
set that assay up it actually worked it
was in I believe 1979 I still have the
gel it shows a very very faint band of
the vsvg protein being processed to
what's called an endo h resistant form
it was very very exciting
Brandi you were originally trained as a
biochemist with one of the master
biochemists Arthur Kornberg you then
began to pursue this problem of membrane
secretion and yeast using a genetic
approach when did you decide it was the
right moment to start to begin a
biochemical dissection of this problem
our approach to initiate with with genex
was always in my mind just a stepping
stone into biochemistry I was not going
to I didn't want to pursue it purely by
genetic analysis I was every intention
of using this to develop some kind of a
cell-free reaction it was a challenge to
get people in my lab to think that way
because when the when something's
working everybody who joins your lab
wants to keep doing that thing you know
I wanted to isolate more mutants that
was great they wanted to clone genes but
convincing any of them to actually take
a step back and and and do something
very different
which to me would have been the obvious
thing what was was was tough so
fortunately after about six or seven
years David Baker joined the lab and he
was brash and considered our efforts in
that direction in inefficient
ineffective and and within two weeks he
had developed a cell-free reaction that
reproduces the first half of the
secretory pathway in vitro and from that
from that point on everyone who joined
the lab said okay I want to do the
biochemistry Hughes was obvious
oh how valuable that would be so what's
the lesson here I guess you know you
have to have the courage of your own
convictions to be persistent and I think
in that particularly this kind of a
biochemical approach if you had success
in that in the past you have as an
article of faith this really certainty
that you can do it again and I felt
confident that that we could and of
course Jim had succeeded so I felt
doubly confident that we could do it and
but that was that was a plan right from
the start
Jim I know you were originally trained
as a physicist then you did beautiful
physical chemistry work with Eugene
Kennedy and eventually you managed to
mature your the research problem in
particular trafficking to the point
where you were able to get purified
membranes and purified proteins the
snare proteins and reconstitute a
membrane fusion reaction so that must
have been a very satisfying moment and I
was wondering if you can explain how you
got to that particular transition or you
could study this problem in this really
well-defined manner the history of that
work was we were left logically with NSF
snap and snares as the components of the
fusion machinery bill Whitner did an
experiment that in his vacuole fusion
system that had established actually
that NSF does not participate directly
and at NSF and snaps do not directly
participate in the fusion reaction per
se when put together with our earlier
finding that the ATP hydrolysis by NSF
disrupts the snare complex he
essentially educated us somewhat
reluctantly I might add that that that
that NSF must be it while it's critical
to energize the system is is acting
either after the fusion reaction or or
or prior to separate a pre-existing
snare complex in any case had left the
snares pardon me as the only logical
candidate so with that in mind I would
say we weren't surprised that the snare
complex mediated fusion and later that
year Reinhard Yun and Axel burger had
published the x-ray structure which
showed a hairpin arrangement and so it
all really came together you know in
that respect in 1998 and you might say
since then we've been trying to study
more or less the physical chemistry the
my current focus is it's the still
unresolved problem of exactly how
calcium synaptotagmin and complex and
put a break on fusion at the last
millisecond in the case of the synapse
and how they orchestrated in a highly
amplified in synchronous fashion the
release of the neurotransmitters that
also is a problem at physical
biochemistry which which I find
enormously satisfying so it's sort of
fun for me at the end you know towards
the end of a relatively long career it's
been 40 years almost in research since I
left University to come back and and
have an opportunity to really take this
problem to the structural and
biochemical level so I'm curious when
you first became aware of each other's
work and also while all these exciting
developments were happening each of your
own labs were the two of you in
communication with one another we were
in touch with each other I mean after
all Jim was at Stanford I was at
Berkeley we actually had one or two day
long joint group meeting - was it - you
know there was some tension between us
at the time I think it was because you
know we both wanted to make our name and
you know and it was a new area and we
were carving out our own approach and
that was I was still were very much
communicate yeah and it was very open
yeah and I'll tell you something that's
a little different today
often times I mean there was I there was
never time that you didn't share an idea
with me that you were thinking about
that we were doing exactly the same
experiment yeah and I would I always
felt comfortable talking to you about
something that I was thinking about even
before we started the experiment because
you know it's just there's a there's a
certain pride of craftsmanship and
respect that that really good colleagues
have even if they are competitive with
each other I think we always had that
yeah there was but there was still
tension and I think that that dissolved
later on especially when it became clear
that we we had identified genes that
were encoding the proteins that he was
studying at that point actually it I
think we both felt that we could make it
you know we could establish ourselves at
the same time but through you know
different different approach so
obviously both of you have had
incredibly exciting careers in the field
of membrane trafficking if you had a
chance to do it all over again right now
would this be the scientific problem
that you would pursue Jim and I've had
this conversation which is if we were
young again would we would we start in
this field all over again and you know
in 2013 and the answer for very personal
reasons is no I would not and I think
Jim shares this feeling now I wouldn't
use it because you know it's relatively
mature field I think there are many
interesting things to discover but you
know judge you know you heard what I
said earlier I wanted to make my own
identity I didn't want to be in someone
else's shadow
and and so for that reason if I were
starting over again I would pick
something brand-new that was what was
under explored and where where I'd have
a lot of time and freedom to to develop
a novel approach and and and you know
and make new discoveries really
significant new discoveries and so I
don't mean to discourage people from
thinking that way but I could say and
another level I totally bruised but you
said Randy but it all depends on your
scientific focus so if I was a young I'm
a professor of chemistry at you I'm
getting a lot of interest in my work now
from the chemists you know because at
another level this is now a problem that
where the biology is considered
relatively solved nothing has ever
completely solved Nobel Prizes aren't
given out for stuff that isn't basically
solved on the other hand it's a problem
that's just been defined from the point
of view of the physical biochemistry and
the chemical biology that can come from
it
so depending on your worldview for cell
biologists or developmental biologists
there's probably other things to do that
are really bigger challenges today for
chemists physical chemists even
physicists and people interested in
modeling it's a really really primary
you